sup y'all this miles bridges my boy
mello just won a rookie here but he
don't know it yet
watch this
nice ain't it i think he's coming hold
on
i ain't got a lot of workouts hey they
were doing me today man
they had me shooting a lot playing a lot
i mean
weight room so yeah it was a great day
at work very good
action now i need speed a little harder
you feel me three pointers
could be a little higher pass passing
the leak
yeah it's looking cool though i ain't
going to cap and be
dunked to the horde all right i need the
dunks i need the ducks like mine
now the big question is if you're going
to run a game of nba jam right now which
of these dudes you going with
you you know you know you really got to
ask that question come on
man you already know
i thought the hardest question you
messed with this shirt bro
yes bro i said envy with the envy you
missed this one bro
oh that's hard now this time it's tough
yes sir what about this game huh
let me take something ain't gonna let me
take man home
you're not even looking gang oh
[Applause]
oh man congrats brother
here bro congrats bro you already know
heavy